Secretary of State Mike Pompeo is in
Seoul to meet tomorrow with South
Koreans president moon jae-in they will
talk about president Trump's decision to
temporarily halt joint military
exercises that moves surprise Seoul
along with top Pentagon officials and
some members of Congress many
Republicans were cautiously optimistic
about the meeting with Kim jong-un but
some say key elements are missing from
the agreement to ensure de ization the
Trump administration responds that the
National Security Council LED
preparations for the summit and created
an aggressive dismantlement timeline US
officials consulted experts on
verification nuclear fuel and safely
taking apart weapons CBS News military
and homeland security and on sandy
Winnefeld is a retired Navy admiral and
former vice chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff he served as commander of the
North American Aerospace Defense Command
the organization tasked with preventing
air attacks against North America
Admiral good morning good morning the
president says we're going to end war
games where the US and Republic of Korea
forces engaged in war games
we don't usually call them games war
games is more of a technical term that's
used for experimentation that sort of
thing these were really high-level joint
exercises combined exercises with a very
important partner obviously on the
Korean Peninsula
those are readiness exercises aren't
they what the purpose do they serve
well they do two things that are very
important the first one obviously is
deterrence and they've worked very well
for decades in deterring North Korean
from attacking the south as part of that
the second thing is that they allow two
nations militaries that come from
different cultures speak different
languages to prepare for combat together
in this CAPTCHA Kachina which means we
go together mode in a potential
high-intensity combat environment that
could happen on short notice in very
short space they're very important it
was interesting when I was there in May
the 8th Army says ready to fight tonight
they call it the closest joint military
cooperation in the world between two US
forces and because of that it means
there can be less US troops there
because the South Koreans are helping
them could they turn on a dime then
and restart these joint military
exercises thicker and that's what's so
important about these negotiations and
that is are we gonna trade reversible
for reversible and irreversible for
irreversible are we gonna try to get the
better side of that and in this case
it's a big deal to trade something like
this but it's also very reversible you
can snap your fingers and do an exercise
tomorrow if Jim mattis is so speaking of
Jim mattis in the Pentagon are they
behaving do you think like as the
president said there is no longer a
nuclear threat from North Korea so the
tactical matter well this is about
capability and intent the capability is
still there and everybody knows it
perhaps the intent on North Korea's part
to use these weapons has been modulated
a little bit by this particular event
that's just happened but you have as a
military person you always take
capability in mind and that's what this
negotiation is going to be all about
dismantling that capability one of the
other chips on the table the president
can use in addition to these training
exercises is the number of US troops in
South Korea let's imagine as the
president suggested down the line and
the negotiation those troops would be
removed there how strategically would
that affect the u.s. posture in the
entire region because obviously China is
a major concern for the US would that
affect it or could the US have troops in
other places in the region and still
deal with the threats in the area well
first of all China loves us they would
love to diminish us and influence in the
region and part of that is the number of
troops we have and where they're placed
interestingly Kim jong-un didn't ask for
that as a concession he pointedly said
it but I'm not worried about that but
President Trump may want to bring some
of these folks home it will impact our
ability to respond in the region but
those troops are really focused on the
Korean Peninsula right so if let's say
that a Korean War ends and that's part
of this deal could those troops be
placed elsewhere in the area they could
be that would depend largely on Japan or
Australia or another ally on the region
allowing us to move the those troops say
in a phased approach out of the region
but it would be wise to keep that
presence there as a counterbalance to
some other players in the region who
might be problematic president tweeted
that were safer today because of that
summit yesterday what's your take away
he's clearly feeling very good about it
and how things turned out
I'm very cold I'm very cautiously
optimistic Gayle you know when you think
of all possible futures
Griffen from men in black 3 this alien
be everything see them all I think this
was a pretty good start too
good future the question now is what
comes next and that's you know this was
easy compared to what comes next in
terms of the very very difficult
negotiations in terms of dismantling
this capability in a phased process it's
gonna have to be phased we're gonna have
to very carefully again trade reversible
for reversible and not fall into the
same trap we might have father certainly
more work to be done
thank you absolutely sandy always good
to have you at the table thank you so
much